the city where it all began is back up
on its feet again
the last patients left this field
hospital in Wuhan and the facility has
now shut China is slowly moving on from
a crisis that America is still in the
thick of and Donald Trump is looking for
someone to blame I'm instructing my
administration to halt funding of the
World Health Organization while a review
is conducted to assess the World Health
Organization's role in severely
mismanaging and covering up the spread
of the corona virus the backlash has
been Swift Bill Gates the wh o--'s
second largest donor tweeted to say that
halting funding for the World Health
Organization during a world health
crisis is as dangerous as it sounds and
the director general of the derecho made
his feelings perfectly clear we regret
the decision of the President of the
United States to order a halt in funding
to the World Health Organization this is
a time for all of us to be united in our
common struggle against a common threat
a dangerous enemy there is another angle
to this and that is Donald Trump's
dislike of the United Nations and the
fact that he's chosen now to have this
battle with the direct show shows really
the failure of the UN to have any kind
of real influence during this global
pandemic the White House hasn't decided
how or when it will cut off funding and
the dollar heo says it doesn't know yet
what the effect of it will be but you
don't lose your biggest donor and just
carry on as normal
whi had no independent means to check
what china was doing China would not let
it on the ground and so should wh o have
praised China maybe not but at the same
time remember President Trump was also
praising China just as effusive ly the
w-h-o isn't the first multinational
organization to feel Donald Trump's
anger
but never has the u.s. president chosen
his timing quite like this if Trump
wanted impact he's got it if he wanted
support
he hasn't Alister bungle Sky News New
York